a lot of people still talking about  president Trump's very blustery dark and  controversial speech to the UN General  Assembly yesterday one reaction in  particular has gone viral under if you  saw this it's president Trump's chief of  staff John Kelly who was sitting in the  audience during that speech here's a  picture of him clearly not clearly not  loving it that was during one of the  many moments when President Trump went  off script here's another one where  again he's really not happy okay here's  this change thing then Trump goes on and  he gets more uncomfortable later on  check this out a third hand was covering  his face  yeah then it got worse he assumed the  crash position I don't know if you saw  this one Benny Benny covered his face  with a Halloween mask he really wasn't  happy about it  finally Kelly left replace himself with  this very crude dummy  [Applause]  you